gens qui regardent en replay mais du
coup pas forcément bon soir mais
peut-être bon jour on démarre on peut
ainsi une petite élite en avance on va
attendre on va attendre lisicki qui
devrait arriver d'une seconde d'une
seconde à l'autre
peut-être à la prochaine seconde
d'ailleurs on va voir on va attendre et
comme ça je vais pouvoir regarder ce que
tout vérifier que tout soit bien bien en
place pendant ce temps là il doit
arriver pile à 20 heures il est pile 21
heures il doit arriver pile koala le
tout pile il va nous faire un tout pile
alors on va pas se prendre on se prend
les pubs sur ma propre chaîne
mais ça veut dire qu'on est en direct
donc on va ouvrir le chat tranquillement
on va voir le cha tranquillement tac tac
tac up
le chat est ouvert on va aller sur une
chaise comme chez ce point comme tv ce
que ce soir c'est fabien qui va jouer on
va je suis fabien ce soit on va suivre
les exploits de fabien on va suivre les
exploits de fabien et on va espérer que
ça se passe je vais vérifier comme on
n'est pas là que ce soit bon parce que
je me suis pris la pub mais du coup j'ai
même pas vérifié si le truc était live
et oui je parle je fais voilà non c'est
bon c'est bon je vais essayer gens
devraient arriver et fabien devrait
aussi arriver incessamment sous peu
c'est bien cette expression très heureux
de mon expression mais ils devraient
arriver maintenant
ramène la bière qui no spoil sur la
vidéo avec ap sol et non le seul spoil
que je peux donner c'est pas un vrai
sport c'est qu'il y aura une deuxième
vidéo on a fait 2 on a tous les deux
vidéos avec avec alexis et donc ça
c'était la première il y aura y aura une
suite y aura une suite j'espère que ça
que les vidéos vous ont plu n'oubliez
pas de mettre 6 1 pouces bleus sur les
vidéos dab sol et de vous abonner à sa
chaîne je fais je fais service
après-vente de la vidéo avec apple
donc c'est sympa est vraiment sympa
absolue comme dans les vidéos j'espère
que là le que la partie qu'on a joué
avec lui vous plaira je regardais des
commentaires d'un salon de famille
arrive il va il va arriver on sait qu'on
va le faire jouer aujourd'hui fabien il
ya déjà pas mal de vue il ya pas mal de
like plus de live sur la chaîne d'absolu
confie une vidéo sonne un par un les
commentaires positifs des gens ont l'air
contents donc c'est cool
attention que les gens attendaient cette
vidéo depuis un moment alors on va
récupérer fabien up fabien qui est la
bio niveau fabien fabien caméra nous
sommes en direct
ouais salut à tous car au regard la
vidéo avec cap sole fait boxer les faits
plus de vue que nous absolue mais en
fait il fait pareil de vue quand on
vient sur ces vidéos si coiffe ont fait
pas fuir les spectateurs non tu vas fuir
les spectateurs
moi je suis je bien calmes et arminé
attend à ces mois là qu'il est dehors de
caméras mines et j'ai dit aux gens que
tu allais jouer ce soir à quoi bah je
sais pas larry ce que les gens veulent
du théâtre échec est ce que jean
quelques que volts il en fait attend bel
et bien d'autres cadres et c'est ok on
est sur twitter on est sûr twitch je
viens très cadré c'est pas toujours
évident et quel est l'effet net skype
mais ça va le faire
donc j'avais futur twitch pouvoir le
chat
bonjour à tout le monde moi j'étais
peut-être un poil proche de ta caméra
banon va je suis comme d'hab en fait
quand on enregistre genre aujourd'hui et
je vois que oui je sais zoomer sur mon
gros front mais en fait rien les chances
que c'est skype qui abrite skype
je me vois normal quant à la distance
non non non on va faire les trucs
différemment t'inquiète pas
j'aime être comme ça à temps moi je vais
mettre ça comme ça et je vais mettre
dans ma vie mettre là en fait on va là
c'est déjà pas mal
donc là on est bon on a cadré les gens
disaient lohan cfad libye qu'il y ait
l'eau dans le châtel c'est toi tu te dis
bonjour à toi la vidéo chat ont voté oui
non mais j'ai compris était palpable
quoi tu fais de l'action le chat est un
mot le terrain ici je vais écrire
salut a tous fait un salut tout le monde
salut tout le monde saluait avec m ça va
paraître voulu stream qui nous écrit
salut tout le monde salue pas mais
qu'elle salue blitzkrieg bout fable
évident l'ocha ati sont là bas alors
vous pourrez chatter donc la soirée en
fait ben t'as vu ça sera beaucoup plus
intéressant oui oui mais c'est parti
comme ça grc
c'est un chat parce que les gens de
discorde sont là quoi il ya madrid
stream tiamat ils se disent qu'elles se
grefferont ims mat et faire ouais il qu
il commence à sentir tu vois comment
rendre ces pseudos plus intéressant tu
voyais 2008 rim dedans quoi ça rappelle
le moment où là et c'est quand il est
devenu français
ouais il a demandé est-ce que je peux
m'appeler vlad blitz quoi ils les ont
pas laissés changer de nom de famille je
m'appelais flat beat se dégager avec
quatre chefs tête ont fait un petit peu
d'échecs normaux puis après on ira vers
le dr frachon ce film cet échec de cette
vidéo des chats k4 pour rim s'est
expliqué avec les tours la nation donc
chez quoi je joue aux échecs en direct
en trois minutes
ouais ou je sais pas si quelqu'un dans
le tchad veut jouer contre toi je pense
à matt bitstream vous pouvez me défier
et patronales by day ce point comme il
veut peut-être se faire [ __ ] et quoi
lui qui veut tout le temps tout frais
tout le monde je voudrais brésilien
poutres et les gens déjà pas si mal
bisri manif
question de newbie pourquoi twitch
plutôt que youtube en direct pourquoi
dix corps plutôt que lé chat intégré
alors la question bottes un peu toi la
tendance alors tweet je sais pourquoi
parce que ils sont partenaires de check
point comme ils veulent développer le
truc c'est pour ça qu'on est là bon jal
nous on est très content d'être sur
youtube roues à youtube hisser notre
notre chaîne quoi à big three m'a
replacé sa chaise points comme donc bon
on reste les mêmes un seul problème mais
tant qu'à faire on est mieux faire ça à
domicile quoi on est mieux être à
domicile qu'à l'extérieur tous derrière
on joue à l'extérieur la dérive taylor
jour jeux extérieurs à risque y déployer
notre jeu bon par exemple phadia quand
même un avantage de beauté extérieure
compte double alors après soir des
discours des chat intégré ça je sais pas
quoi dire non c'est le soutien non mais
discorde c'est quoi c'est un peu le chat
de la communauté parce que ma femme et
moi on n'est pas tout le temps live
peut-être qu'on devrait faire un temps
de refaire un réalité des réalités tv
qu'elle et fab
bon ça fait un petit match et après si
on est à dire qu'elle est faible dans le
titre mais je fais du moustoir même 000
ce mode jeu sinon mais c'est un mec du
life c'est parti j'ai accepté le défi
mais faut jouer la demi seconde de
retard mais les divisions qui de par les
pendre donc c'est parti j'ai la partie
je passe tu me suis moi je te suis fabi
24,81 représente mais ed 4 500 très
intéressant mais dont john était oui
j'en et a parlé de discorde mais
discorde ont pris donc les chat le chat
les machins les trucs bon c'est bien
quand quelque part
on est là il fait tout ça mais bon après
quand on n'est pas live enfin si la
communauté veut rester discuter ensemble
parler d'échec
a fortiori c'est un peu le seul chat
d'échec slash forum de france yahia on
n'a pas d'autre en fait en entièrement
libre quoi alors au lieu de faire 6 4
vous voulez affût des stands de merde je
peux vous dire c'est bien le v4 ou f4
dame b 4 échecs bon donc il ya le mét on
verra mais ils font des deux dames prend
b2 qui a laissé trois fresques où je les
tiendrai et d'un projet de caisse et 3
est en fait juste à jouer 15 scott adam
t'as rien développé que ces trois venir
en d5 et tu te fait ratiboiser kleinert
la c4 tu es ma chance mais si tu joues
que les biais de touraine mauvaise
surprise je dis ça je dis rien on verra
tu as déjà égalisé 1 finalement fait
l'ouverture elle juste mauvaise même si
les blancs sont pas précis original je
comble avec un bon rock et à 5 tours à 6
comme dans les gants be un candidat ps
exactement budapest a envie on appelle
ça nous rappelle quoi le stage je le
seul à vue d'après vous à d'ailleurs
tiens c'est un truc bien d'y penser on
aurait on devrait gérer un grand milieu
d'appels sympa où des partis ont durant
commenté une refera plus pour le salage
à budapest tout le temps partout
tiens c'est un projet qu'on est sympa
ton plan voilà je pense que ça vaut
mieux faire un truc sympa mais là on
rigole mais je pense et efficace en plus
contre le fus enquêteurs pensent que la
partie que je pense que je pourrai
montrer sur la chaîne le mec se fait
défoncer pour la dope
tu me reste ma tendance ultra sanctions
bah je joue un peu la barre barque dans
l'esprit cela se fait comme suit à
domicile vous compte marquer des buts à
l'extérieur de partout ailleurs le
dispositif spécial pour les candidats on
sera sûr twitch quand même mais le tweet
du bitstream donc là on sera sur terrain
neutre
ouais bon comme d'hab vous préfèrerais
de youtube mais bon allez on va faire
plaisir chez ce point comme weppes yvon
il ya aussi la russie twitch il faut le
dire un qui nous propose de nous mettre
en première page de twitch français
[ __ ] international mondial quoi les
mecs se disent s'il vous plaît souvent
ok tout sauf et avisé sa et à temps
j'allais dire un autre truc away en plus
j'ai une bonne idée là l'erreur je
l'écris ça marche pas mon âge tu vas
faire damageux kg 3 mais bon sang
meursault d'armes et ont pilonné ouais
mais bon je suis pas sûr qu'ils parlent
vraiment tu pas calculer un perso et
donc je disais ouais en plus assez le
beau jeu tourache un échec dans la
prochaine fois tu pourras les cc mettez
sur pause machin belle victoire tapez
outré
alors il ya dirso chess qui veut jouer
est ce que ces gagnants du chat est
quelqu'un du chat mais j'accepte il jean
colmar et donc oui tu sais ce qui se
sont proposés de faire alors après le
raid en train de monter une équipe
femmes mais tu étais pas là mardi soir
mais on est en train de monter une
équipe pour que les gens qui regardent
le live sur twitter
fan du montage pendant les candidats
pour qu'on est une version montée sur
youtube l'un des pays au monde et du
direct des candidats bah si jamais vous
pouvez le faire bien sûr c'est très bien
ce que gagne un temps fou et c'est cool
et ce serait la première fois de la
communauté visée il travaillera ensemble
main dans la main un peu ce qu'on voudra
arrive à faire un jour quoi souris dans
la soufflerie dans la souris mais il
était chaud à la fin on a trouvé deux
mecs qui étaient chauds il dit ouais si
on se relaie qu'on travaille bas avec
plaisir bien sûr si vous voulez faire
des choses soient sans toutes les bonnes
volontés sont les bienvenues
donc mon seigneur très bonne idée très
bien je reparlerai mardi prochain mardi
pendant la prochaine mercredi quand il
ya des projets sli quand il ya du monde
et je vais organiser sur discorde une
chaise spéciale machin enfin bon tu as
un endroit spécial pour avec les gens
puissent s'organiser ouais mais bon faut
les faire bosser aussi à la communauté
parfois tu vois on met la main à la pâte
oui quelle patate ou blanches
[Rires]
des fois on réussit vraiment à parler de
n'importe quoi à la foule des quatre
taxes aux in bien bon plein de manières
de jouer je ne sais pas peut faire un
pas tant parce que ceux des ressauts de
chasse est un ami je connais la personne
est-ce que ça le rend plus dangereux je
ne sais pas mais peut-être transition
tout faux
d'ailleurs je vais manger chinois après
ce stream chinois de la gare non il est
fermé le soir mais chinois de la gamme
j'ai mangé mardi avant le title tuesday
qui n'a pas eu lieu dans toute chose a
porté chance
voyez je suis très content qu'il ait pas
de légumes et j'étais très heureux quoi
d'ailleurs pour le bon il est pas à
baisser pour marin tour mardi prochain
donc si je suis doublement heureux
il rate le chinois fait complètement une
fois qu'on l'a ni l'hôtel de tous
d'accord non mais vraiment fantastique
ce chinois forcément quand on est une
question de vlad quoi ces prix en plus
on ne ment pas quoi ces objets seront
faut le savoir
mais c'est vrai c'est pour festi info
vlad alors brosse un bon c'est pas tout
ça
bobby fischer qui accepte mon défi je
suis fait chier fedj qu'exigerait
pourquoi t'es pas bobby fischer en fait
forcément bien fait secouer sur pièces
comme des mouches les beats et chasser
ben je sais pas moi
chose comme ça sourit faisais n'importe
quoi j'ai fait pas rêver ramener mon
cabas l'hiver est simple il aurait pu
partir en des caps tout seul je sais pas
là j'avais perdu les arènes du truc
c'est un cheval fou je m'intéresse
non non non je ne sais pas pourquoi
annoncer un mec qui fait une simultanée
milanovic ouais mais bon enfin j'ai
regardé ça cimeterre franchement je
regardais son stream avantage mais jetez
un coup d'oeil ludique
bah forcément on ne met que ce dictateur
c'est pas quoique nous paraît pas pas
rivaliser
260 spectateurs non mais là encore il
vous regarde pas sinon bon d'ailleurs
plus que nous on est 30 quand même allez
on est bien ouais ça craint les mecs
retour de fab libye on est sûr en
revanche c'est que la vidéo la première
vidéo tu fais des beats pour la première
fois à la surface comme elle est arrivée
à 7800 vu quoi les mecs fabi libye qui
ce type
montre nous comment jouer aux échecs tu
vois ma montre nous comment ne pas jouer
son nom mais je suis un peu déçu là de
l'année 31 mai a dit je vais peut-être
me connecter on sera 32 bat toujours sur
cette trip match mais au fait pourquoi
mediamath va défier je vais accepter
matin définit cette partie mais pour ne
pas alors faire simultanée machin je
sais pas on peut surtout et je compte
bien trop sinon qu'il est entre nous
sans disque dur est jamais si je suis
trop habitués aux screen youtube c'est
pour ça que va faire affaire hyper
attention pendant les candidats parce
qu'il ya plein de mecs qui vont pas
d'ailleurs vous qui êtes là donc il
savait qu'on va on va s'exprimer sur sur
sur salat sur twitch peut-être vous
pouvez relier l'info ce qu'évidemment il
y aura besoin du bouche à oreille et
tout ça l'espagne tient bon on va dire
groupe toute façon rester beaucoup plus
présent sur youtube il ya pas de
problème là-dessus mais mai au caire
c'est comme ça c'est tout ça après il
faut souligner quand même fable que
quand on fait les speechs s les choses
comme ça les gens viennent quand même
naturellement après sur le switch vient
ils sont courants donc là comme on
ferait une grosse vidéo d'annoncé pour
les candidats vous parlera un peu des
forces en présence et tout ça donc ça du
mandat de chef il faut vraiment que tu
lepoutre 1
à tanger lucas 0,05 ce qui ça mais c'est
de poutres et battait faire partie des
sélectionnés ont mis un prêt streaming
youtube ça fonctionne bien pour rameuter
ouais mais pendant les candidats si on
commence à faire des prêts stream
youtube malheureusement eu c'est vrai un
mais
c'est difficilement fera une vidéo
d'annoncé youtube de toute façon le dira
et je ferai peut-être un prêt stream
avant la première ronde
je faisais rien du cfbb s
moi je l'appelle cesse de s'allonger
complètement enfin c'est fini en fait
ils s'appellent cette baisse mais il
s'appelle mais après on aimerait
vraiment un pour le truc des montages
s'il ya des gens j'en reparlerai 1 mais
si on pouvait faire monter une petite
équipe de 5 6 pour faire des replays sur
youtube le soir je les mette le
lendemain matin en ligne qui font genre
30 minutes une heure maxi ce serait
vraiment très cool de votre part ça nous
éviterait nous d'avoir à faire les récap
en fait là machin qu'on fera les jours
on ne peut pas ce trimestre ne peut pas
tout faire ça je pousse tous les pions
attention il joue pas mal hein des
recettes de best il faut il faut s'en
méfier mozilo plus fous sont tous tous
pour toi et je me tape les indous un
pousseur de bois du coup favorablement
ford espère car il ya deux géants lutter
pour refermer la savate avec plaisir
tant pis en pis tant pis quoi match est
ce qu'ils demandent quel est le plan
pour ce stream barrière fab libye qui
jouent contre les spectateurs bon ben
c'est le plan tranquillou dans un
mouvement est d'ailleurs fac je pense
qu'on va aussi stream et d'autres jeux
pendant les candidats ça se peut qu'on
juin par exemple boeing d'ailleurs
pendant les comptoirs je sais pas ce que
ça me situe non en fait c'est simple je
t'annonce le topo du jeu je vais
l'acheter la ja ja il ya une apocalypse
de zombies
il n'y a plus que des zombies d'actifs
survivre le plus longtemps possible mais
tu es sûre et sur de mourir ingénieurs
de mourir un jour et est donc est donc
en fait je lui dis des candidats a
certainement ça va être tellement de la
merde parce que tu es toutes les
positions seront nuls qu'on va faire
chier tout le monde jouera à ça on s'en
fout complètement
non ce sera très heureux non d'armes
je serais très content du coup ce sera
le premier vrai ce crime des chats cool
de se faire chier à rien raconté à
chialer du lourd à dire eux c'est nu les
parties sinueuses
on ira on ira on admire à taper du
zombie voilà non mais j'ai voulu dire
c'est de la merde on ira s'amuser c'est
peut-être mieux fâche sébastien est un
nouveau concept de string d'échec on
fait des échelles des secours se marque
ouais ouais ou sa lose quand le truc
tout fait chier en fait on va taper du
zombie dégagé ou d'autres joueurs si
vous avez des idées d'ailleurs déjà un
peu dans ce style là on peut jouer
tranquille ou quoi on est preneur 6 juin
dès mais j'ai vu il a l'air vraiment pas
mal il ya d'ailleurs le joueur du
grenier qui est en train de faire un lp
narratif dessus à bon prix bas s'ils
grenier si mal or donc il faut payer ou
sinon vous blitz est vrai mais c'est pas
l'objectif de faire plus d'échecs à
programme premier scream déchets coûte
on se permettra de maréval de rigoler
c'est parti je vais retrouver une partie
de zombies c'est fantastique parce que
j'étais très content de prouver qu'ils
ont des buts tu vois plus benoît se
passe plus rien alors qu' on prend et
dams et de nantua rentre et je sais pas
ce que je fais tu ailles à royal il ya
plein de super cool affaire au sérieux
des haches des jeux indés sympa
n'hésitez pas en fera des jeux mais
c'est pareil c'est des jeux où on peut
discuter et on peut faire avec fable
monter des stratégies quoi donc la
preuve avec son bi son bolide c'est sur
nos stratégies ça va être de survivre
top et des zombies on aura un objectif
survivre en fait un mur zombies donc on
jouera on jouera peut-être de bruit à
d'autres choses et on fera un peu de
cash royal de temps en temps aussi on
enverra des cochons bah moi non mais pas
oui mais le remède france screen cher tu
seras là la merde
une chose qui est pas content j'ai
l'impression qu'ils rient vilches
l'impression qu'ils se dit trop de
zombies arrivent
philippe tu as if i pas fluide qui
rajoute un thé arrivé à lyon il dit j'ai
des problèmes de network depuis hier je
n'arrive pas à suivre directement vers
ça n'a aucun rapport avec les zombies
oui pour les zombies mais il ne s'est
même pas en fait ouais celle de seb un
set dub est cette baisse donc c'est
important parce que c'est ridicule
bien bien bien bon sang quelle grigris
ti-breizh quoi il connaît un plan de
versus zombies qui était un autre jeu
fantastique c'est bien ça c'est un vrai
jeu est très intéressante d'ailleurs
caruana la forme inspirée pour cause
bonjour aux échelles ont complètement il
a tout à fait raison
bon bah je souffre
mettons pas en soi qui n'a plus trop de
temps d'ailleurs même lui non plus
ça j'ai pas compris la à ok il veut trop
bien joué
bon c'est pas où on va faire un coup
bien sûr mon très mauvaise en brouillon
la situation quoi qu'est ce que c'est
que ça je fais contre embrouillée de fer
touré fils bien joué et l'orangé faut
qu'ils fassent tomber et femmes
je passe tu vas y arriver moi je pense
que si jean basset attention pratique
qu'est ce que c'est que ça bon bin adam
ouais mais tu vas faire là je tiens ces
chaussées chauffage je crois que c'est
toi qui l'a trouvée femmes
cette baisse qui ne retient gagner et
bien jouer bien joué cette de best way
comme quoi parler d'eux on dit ça peut
aider les spectateurs
j'ai toujours lu cas que je bats apprend
lui 47 ans mais est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un du du truc à je pense drapeau
français 2106 un petit jedi ce thème
obi-wan obi-wan kenobi obi wan kenobi
réponse 2 je sais pas un big one kenobi
j'aime pas trop but yohann kenobi je
sais pas pourquoi tu vois il est là on
est dans devant son lac dont il médite
quoi enfin j'ai pas je suis parent je
comprends pas le avec projet enfin
gilles tu pourras le projet d'obi wan tu
vois je comprends plus le projet dark
vador si tu veux tu as quelque part
choisi une planète je te fais une étoile
noire je l'a détruit coiffe un vieux jeu
courant vraiment ce que veut faire le
mec obi wan
non bon il ya un hobbit ou d'ailleurs ce
que j'ai dit oh be one
quelque part on attend une suite on peut
le prendre ou ne pas prendre au vol de
rentes pour l'instant attention bonbons
à le prendre maintenant tu vas faire un
pion en d5 derrière belle victoire en
coach s il ya un fab
voilà j'ai comme une peinture arrivé à
la fin et on gagne à quoi du coup c'est
bon moi j'ai fait mon job je n'ai pas
regardé quoi ouais on les a bien
manoeuvré femmes ouais ouais quoi très
fort en manoeuvre l'équipe c'est bon
c'est sûr et semaine prochaine mercredi
prochain lors d'un match très important
contre les bulles fines
ils peaufinent ce faire de film de
reykjavik
ils ont l'air dangereux malgré des
stocks toujours qui surperforment
attention dangereux ils ont des joueurs
très dangereux il faudra il faudra les
mettre en danger
c'est à dire beaucoup de danger dans ce
match non mais en plus ils le prennent
au meilleur moment ils nous prennent
pendant paris paris real factuel et m
une oreille sur les échappements et sur
1 sur le foot
ils nous prennent à revers en demandant
à reporter le match mais je vais
peut-être faire un mail
on jouera du foot ya de la neige c'est
de la neige ce week-end on joue tout est
léger
enfin qu'est ce que c'est que ça ne sera
pas psg real media real psg ouais c'est
machado mtq a lancé sept c'est dommage
je pense autrement at what u gagné la
partie directe mais bon là ça va suffire
mais j'aurais pu aller verser cette
royale 1604 il regardera plus tôt la
prochaine si que psg real bon alors
c'est vrai mais quelque part toi aussi
non mais moi je sais pas dans quel état
serait que j'aurai mon opération et rare
opération du nez c'est là la première
fois 7 à quasiment rien fait non non
mais c'est pas vraiment eu de la chance
un bouquet je suis pas inquiet mais bon
quand on investit 10 local coach va
crever déjà dormi un peu de jeu je sais
pas ce qu'a réussi local sais rien tu
peux demander à bosse là qui est dans le
tchat
mais j'ai pas donc on verra je viens de
mon avis là dessus veut commenter mais
je pense pas tu pense pas qu'il veuille
ouais je pense pas
non je sais pas mais je demanderai en
fait nous la faisons nous arrêt sera un
match hyper important plus parce que si
on les bat c'est quoi ce délire pas de
fin
ok c'est déjà maintien à 100 % web en
deux journées et calif
il nous manquera peut-être un match nul
ou une victoire mais peut-être même pas
en fait enfin avoir suivant fait ça
dépendra des matches internationaux mais
comme je pense que l'on international on
va tous se faire [ __ ] et parce qu'il y
aura les chinois les machins les trucs
bat déjà en fait j'arrive à être appelle
les américains qu'ils avaient poutrer
l'année dernière la douce k-way à boyce
eux ils sont derniers de la ligue
américaine
c'est les plus nuls c'est plus vous avez
vie douce 4 avait pas vu le jour après
cette année cette année il ya les
caméras aussi est ce que tu vois ça mais
ce que ça change
mais où cet effet plus très quoi on
s'était fait défoncer donc
bon je sais d'avancé mais pions petit à
petit j'en dis ce que tu as raté une
tour en un coup en fait c'est tellement
gagnant ses positions que c'est pas
c'est pas facile à danser concentra
marais de la séance
kenza crois que non n'importe quoi ça va
oui mais bon ça reste un gagnant non
mais c'est pas facile à rester
concentrée d'un vote le truc pas évident
mais toi tu gères bien c'est de parler
en jour parce que doit dur de faire des
trucs en même temps est ce qu'il ya
encore plusieurs préfèrent souvent c'est
de parler de tes propres coups de thé
variantes en en parlant mais un jour 11
ans j'y arrive en 3 + 2 mais quand même
plus de temps sur la pendule zermatt en
fait j'avais eu le cas de figure ce que
je te dise quand je vais je vends de
shorts une partie des émissions comme ça
on est l'un et l'autre bon là c'est
d'expliquer nos coûts en fait ok enfin
quand je parlais gers je me sentais
parla de haller s'est fracturé deux
tchèques en même temps pas je faisais du
navire l'autre je parlais comme un
débile et jeu
au fond on a fait nul quoi mais la
partie était insipide mais justement
j'essaie d'éviter toutes les
complications peuvent échanger des trucs
j'étais contente mais c'est pas évident
entre 15 et dur de change de la fois
comme magnus il a essayé j'ai du mal
aussi de raconter comment tu a recruté
vanina dans l'équipe de calme nous
souhaitons que je sache les gens font
c'est une histoire de vue sur
intéressante non intéressant mais en
fait la finale était être un peu en
couple avec avec laurent fraisse et du
groupe de leucémie un peu mieux
connaître les français tous à votre
enfin je ne sais pas quoi la meuse
enfin gérard choqué je la passe et deux
non tu vois chaque jeu pas mal pour deux
mille cinq cents lots aux portes des
mines mais j'avais trop le portier dû
parler et la dupont trouver se côtoyer
plus quoi la défense en bois un verre de
machin à se creuser plus souvent donc
après battu voilà donc l'occasion je
demandé s'ils vous je vois là aussi
bêtement que ça il ya une victoire pour
faire me be bon là j'ai refusé la
revanche mais à en croire rejoint
ensuite un luca mais je suis quelqu'un
de jouer évidemment
donc voilà il donc on profite du fait de
la règle que clinton féminine cette
baisse la mayenne et l'eau donc c'est
bien pour une équipe qui joue bien et
est donc pas de l'anti mahb a fait
d'elle picard dangereuse rapide quoi
sont ils arrivés dans les parties des
fois elle va en faire vous pas en forme
mais celle en forme et avait regagné le
toit du monde
mon dernier par exemple dont il peut
faire mal attention et en plus beau et
sympa démarre en boubou très bien quoi
très bien pour les couples ducs de
normandie à l'est on accepte non et
c'est lui qui a gagné le gardien el
tourabi serait donc forcément forcément
dangereux pas ibra j'emploie j'emploie
tout de suite les bonnes ouvertures quoi
pigeot des 4 ou dis comme ça tu es
obligé de te les meilleurs d'ouverture
du monde balayer plus le choix
ouais je sens que c'est même trop facile
cette partie c'est difficile de se
concentrer à une fois que tu as fait une
grande dame a lancé gecas
en fait tu te sens bien huit cents
supérieur quoi ces médecins qui est à ce
point comme l'a encore vu ce qui est
très drôle c'est que au moment où j'ai
joué j'ai quatre c'est là que tout s'est
déconnecté en fait non de bord sa
tutrice je m'attends à des ouvertures
interdite
que fais-tu quoi et la deuxième en fait
ils sont ses parents parce que j'ai fait
une ruse avec les noirs du le temps de
faire justice bouger cette sas a tout
fait péter aussi ils ont senti la revue
d'art et avec quoi ils se sentent dit ça
y est valence où les classiques jeux
vidéo ont comparé à 21h30 à manger
chinois
je sais pas encore si tu es avec nous la
question que tous se posent là on est
quand même 30 sur le live mais nous
qu'elle nous ça va tu vois tout le monde
à la france quoi enfin le peuple de
france
non mais tu te noies en fait bah en fait
je dis nous tout le monde en fait la
communauté bisri mais les gens qui
regardent on est combien la halle on et
130 qui sont 47 merde à bamako sont à la
maison c'est en train d'arriver là à
l'ensemble de la 134e fou combien de
cartes et on va me faire 13 personnes
heureusement à l'ondé remonte à 147 j'en
peux plus on monte on descend c'est le
yoyo mais mon doigt et assure 34 de
twitch quand psl faut qu aux faucons
stabilise qua non mais je pense qu'on
est sur le truc officiel de chez pas
quoi battre les autres choses comme tv
du coudray aller simultanée la
simultanée complètement insipide s'est
arrêté mais attention attention à ce
qu'on dit non non c'est nous yano gueule
avant à merde alors nous on espérait
complètement dépassée il ya plus de 120
agents les gens commencent à partir en
masse se dit ah bon ok les deux idiots
ouais bon
bien bien bien bon bah écoute
qu'est ce qu'on fait je sais pas à 3
d'ailleurs il ya un truc intéressant
[Musique]
ouais il ya un truc intéressant c'est
chaud plat crise yahoo sa semaine
prochaine à tunis
on va peut-être essayer de stream et en
même temps toi sur la chaîne tweet du
bitstream et moi sur la chaîne youtube
lice rim débit stream de partout un
événement ce serait marrant partout
toujours tout le temps est moins fait je
vais jouer mercredi avant la prochaine
ligue 3-0 bas le tournoi de qualifier la
presse donc toi tu pourras furent
extraits après son opération du nez du
jour non mais peut-être pas mercredi
mais il y en a trois noms mais
normalement ça va très mal se passer y
aura pas trop la main mais juste je sais
pas comme notre façon j'avais
l'opération censée être à 18 heures je
me situe à je sais pas non ça 18h le
soir et je dis que je passe là bas oui
même si on sait que c'était le matin du
coup je me faisais pièce que tu vois ce
qu'est ce qui me fait mon femme tu vois
non non mais voilà donc déjà j'ai passé
une matinée sans sera leur avance à la
grande question sera opérée en fait les
mets qui a 10 19 heures enfin dégage baï
faisait bon de commande chez tout
revient demain
ouais donc du coup c'est pour ça je
disais je suis pas sûr de pouvoir jouer
le soir je n'ai pas peur je vais rentrer
et tout ça quoi loria cubic inédite chez
ce bras conceptuellement au dessus ils
font des tournages et 4 parce que t'es
con way des tournois de grave mais bon
d'un autre côté comment tu peux être
conceptuellement au dessus ça ils ont
quand même un train de retard quoi faire
enrager 4 cuillères par la tuer je pense
que les curseurs de l'ontt inju a même
tenu ce qui à fait ok les concepts bon
la loire mais je pense qu'on tue qu'on
pille des concepts vitrine quelque part
sa place quelque part conceptuellement
au dessus des autres mais tu peux pas
être conceptuellement
suit deux créateurs ont-ils un mehdi
ouatine dans leur team quoi on sait pas
enfin mehdi m'a dit que non en tout cas
un génie ce que c'est on leur team il
m'a dit non il a même rigolé ça l'a fait
marrer ça ils se sont inspirés du nul
contre carl crs et ça
sont complètement inspiré attendant bon
soit la dame seule l'udc a pronostiqué
mur comme un cigare un sur quatre y de
heil a pris ce qui d'ailleurs est il
était seul il emporté haut la main quoi
alors attendez-vous matin faire que tu
leur la partie je le vois modifiée
pendant deux jours une fête bat des
défis maintenant la la cc c'est un
moment il ya piero qui me définit ouais
mais matt fr il a beaucoup parlé j'ai
entendu parler çà et là bas tant de
jacques sapir haut dir weh parce qu'il a
parlé ça et là alors pierrot à l'époque
qu'il ya dans mon pote en amont poteau
c'est une sicilienne sur des quatre en
fait intéressant s'apprête à le couper 5
1 qui était quand même très intéressant
là comme ça avant qu'elle et ses 3 navy
l'option c4 c'était quand même aller
pions et sinon vous êtes après quoi son
autre jeune violeur j'ai fait du tournoi
bitstream j'ai fait j'ai fait une pls en
bullet j'ai fait une belle pls très très
belle pls mais moi je me suis dit cave
tu t'es automobile mais mon gt gt chuté
chez des shows j'étais chaud j'ai fait
des blitz comme ça je fais bis conquis
les spectateurs non on a fait des trucs
on a fait des trucs métal eagle il
demande qu'on ait depuis combien de
temps vous jouer aux échecs
c'est un question intéressant de métal
eagle rock big mac ou le géant vie
presse de la paix la glèbe de faire
ouais non un aigle de faire mon père qui
m'a appris quand j'étais petit mais
vraiment petit c'est mon père lui-même à
une licence donc il joue il jouit la
nappe réduit collège du primaire en ce1
à l'école et donc et donc voila quoi
donc ki moon s'est dit tiens tu le
prends aussi
donc j'ai quasiment jeu de toi et toi
moi moi depuis que j'ai 6 ans et demi
c'est mon père qui m'a appris aussi à
tandem père en fils mêmes erreurs si
c'était à refaire
non tu vas apprendre non parce qu'on
joue au foot je mettrai des crucifix ça
dégage je n'ai pu voir cet échiquier tué
mettre un peu d'ail autour aussi tiens
on va chez toi des blues die au marché
seraient très bon supermarché torresi
prend c'est un peu fort mais n'en
comptera autre chose
ton jeu de merde agira très intéressant
comme je préfère jose ont mis est
project zomboid ça c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant comme je leur ai dit je vais
t'apprendre les toits avec le de fer que
nous publions tu joues à la hachette et
crucifie
à d'ouvrir la colonne a pour ta tour moi
je on a un foot + on est tranquille je
pense que plusieurs plans sont
prometteurs sa position est prometteuse
les pierrots qui se bat la raison je
porterai que soit le pierrot qui jouent
avec notre coach estime un autre pierrot
bassam ont quand même très répandu quoi
fia tiers qui est écrit non lol c'est ça
le fait marrer magma dmitri me prends
jamais mon avis qu'il fit plis binôme et
c'est incroyable bonjour jambes je vais
pas rejoué jusqu'à alors bien vite ce
qui a failli et il est tout le temps
chaud quoi j'étais obligé de le [ __ ]
et une fois oui j'étais obligé il
faisait trop le malin quoi j'étais
obligé de
il fait le malin dehors des ignorants
qui fait le malin partout de relever le
gant ouais bah de lepoutre est en fait
je disais ça de mener un peu plus classe
ben ouais
l'élégante c'est pas la pierre aux sept
durant la finale avec une caisse de moi
est un gentleman assez joli cevoli roi
cinq fours en maths
un math mode défi alors ne t'en vas quoi
je finis cette partie après j'accepte et
je dois tout faire en même temps va
bientôt céder non je sais pas voilà
mathon déchets reparti mais un gros défi
la 10e avant mon pierrot
maintenant ma tournée dirso de choses
qui a fait dix sur quatorze
là il s'est bien battu dire ce que tu as
dit sur 14 c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
du tout non on va te faire non alors
c'est une stratégie de maths à faire
c'est à dire qu'il y défient pour c'est
pour ça qu'on est en fait défi pour
englober je peux pas accepter
tu flippes en fait il va y voyez comme
dirait ce tronçon à l'élite chic
colloghan aux caleçons quoi ta procès le
gal himat va nous inventer une déco à la
fin de cette game live à se déconnecter
c'est ça ouais c'est pas bon bah tant
pis façon c'était une philippe est quoi
non mais bon hockey et disparaît à
chaque fois que on a compris je pense à
beaucoup de scientifiques utilisent je
vais écrire je vais écrire sur le
discorde matin sur d'oriens pierre à
j'entends bien bruit mais c'est pierrot
qui meurent au défi mais que je voudrais
bientôt rejouer m on attend matin à
empire romain on parlait sans dans son
match toi tu fait planter le live de ce
soir pas car si j'aime apprendre des
virées si je pense que tu défies pas au
bon moment quoi façon je ne joue plus
ton que t'es pas là donc désolé tous je
vois plein de défis désolé j'aimerais
beaucoup vous affrontez mais tu as plus
important à faire
défi personnel gestion de view demeure
enfin qui sait ce type 2 quel droit il a
dit que j'étais outrée de quel droit ces
des amis ça il se fout de votre gueule
dans le hockey mais c'est fantastique il
est il et il est quand même enfin il le
fait exprès c'est sur quoi elle dérape
son écran il attend sur totale quoi
c'est chez lui c'est une piscine l'a
déjà fait il ya déjà un dégât des eaux
chez les voisins du dessous quoi ils
sont là ils appellent matin faire payer
enfin ce plus que des températures sa
peugeot les coiffeurs ou près du verglas
partout chez toi quoi tu vis dans un
igloo alors pas maté faire c'est parti
ah bon il faut que tu le poutrain la
très sérieuse je devais parler pendant
la partie d'ailleurs un sens
commentaires partie son commentaire dans
le cliché
maintenant je posais ne dit plus rien
tu vas le petit leurs robes
là je veux rien dire pour pas qu'ils
disent kevin la poutre et quoi bon alors
c'est une robe un peu vous conseille pas
de faire son parti nouvel équilibre mais
bon obama diffère en sueur pourquoi pas
saleh est en sursis car contre 4 g 5
il pourra pas dire c'est parce que c'est
un grand maître il connaît des trucs
parker ou quoi tu vois ça va peut-être
que je connais par coeur ou 4g 5 sur les
dix grands maîtres de la mémoire pas des
gares aux quais les ont pas tort qu'ils
ont fait mais bon c'est comme ça de
partout pas un mec qui vont au tennis
thuram et tu as pu le servir
tu triches obligé quoi tu produis 6-8 eu
à passer le bac tu te fais des devoirs
ou [ __ ] qu'est ce que tu sais ce que
tu as fait quoi bah désolé pas situés
dans un domaine de jeudi passé du temps
d'apprendre des choses mais si tu veux
cuisiner faut que tu fais tes recettes
enfin je sais pas n'importe quel doigt
c'est une bonne histoire de messieurs
devenir une fois si tu veux devenir
rappeur bah tu dois rappeler
rappel quoi des carottes des bons
n'importe quoi j'y vois je dis rien dans
cette partie-là j'attends que ça poutre
ont voulu en cours
moi j'ai un objectif que tu pourrais pas
bien bâti mais le message césar celui
qui va mourir que c'est lui mais un
message privé
non mais ça je sur la partie savoir si
la limmat
hier matin quelque part son nom est
prédestiné aaa aaa aaa aaa la sueur
on va manger 1
d'où la longueur totale
est ce que tu penses qu'il a rêvé tu vas
faire l'exploit qua non je sais pas ça
faisait marrer c'est tout elle
m'appelait césar pour sinon qui lie le
rif il fallait ne pas jouer pendant deux
minutes pour le faire souffrir
mais globalement la motive le voir on
peut voir on ne sait pas à l'avancé une
bonne expérience pour mata faire après
non mais il ay leila d'humour il
comprend le second degré t'inquiète pas
ne t'inquiète pas
mais bon
ça lui fait mal un petit bout trage ça
va ouais c'est une petite poutres et
poutrelles
ouais c'est de la poutre l'aide ça c'est
artisanal
as tu appris la dame mais en fait je
suis auto queen tu vas faire un cavalier
jeu comme ça m'allait très bien mais
mais j'ai même pas eu le choix de
choisir mais le luxe de choisir je n'ai
pas le choix de choisir for the sick of
fate m'offre la safer tour pranger deux
tours ça mais ça y est tu les îles on a
triché
attention je suis dit les coups
qu'est ce que tu aurais est ce que tu
aurais trouvé si j'utilisais tu peux
gagner sa salle c'est un peu la question
qu'on se pose
tu as maté en force fab ouais
à ces baumes a attiré 10 puisque
jusqu'au bout quoi là il compte saisir
me déconnecte ou quoi non mais enfin
matt au bout d'un moment voulu je lui
faire croire aux pattes
mais je m'attends prochain
david coa femmes beaucoup mahamat
mais bon là grob encore une fois que j
utilise et ses ouvertures trop puissante
parce s'il a perdu du pronostic à cause
du faux matt qu'on peut avoir l'honneur
d'affronter le val d'anniviers connecte
à dos avec ses boutons comme et défis
des fables et les familles c'est le cdh
le mr est l'adresse d'autres comme on
connaît pas on ne paie pas le nom du
site d'offrir le boss doit être à ce
point c'est ok piero qui rejoue alepian
c'est reparti que l'on regarde ta femme
oui je rejoue quoi sa femme ça l'a
souvent fait qu'est-ce qui me casse les
couilles avec ses parts après midi on va
faire la vaisselle coiffage rends-toi
utile quoi 20 je me demande l'intérêt en
fait
j'arrive pas ouvrir sur le smartphone en
fait depuis tout à l'heure le chat de
chasse points comme tv en fait j'essaie
de faire ça depuis depuis déjà quinze
minutes je n'arrive pas en fait n'est
pas prêt à ça sur padraig offrir le
ouvrir le flux twitter
mais c'est bien c'est intéressant ça
fait twitter twitter ces gamins des
pierres aux endroits du monde chez st
retard c'est un repère et à des
banquiers tu fuis moi j'ai une super
sonne non je suis quelques mecs qui sont
sympas
damas des verts qui et quelle honte
joffre madame bon ça ban dans la partie
contre toi un battu l'offre la paire qua
non il préfère le havre ou offrir ou à
sacrifier quelque part à ce qu'on dit
pierre qui les laisse moi gagner ma
femme regarde quoi
la pauvre elle va se taper nos vidéos
jeudi soir et placés grâce à l'asie
reprenant les deux abrutis maintenant en
direct même avancé que sur youtube sur
tweets chalon surtout surtout celui qui
a plus de cheveux d'ailleurs les plus
cons que votre nom même si même si ce
genre se défont quoi parfois tu te
demandes ce basculement s'ils font pas
un match où 5e dan hallett pierre il dit
c'est exactement ça ça va vous attend
dans ce mariage ici si c'est bien assez
bien à eux deux ils sont très hostiles
l'adversaire l'opération de mercredi
matin mercredi après la dune est une
arme une anesthésie locale tu as elle
peut se dire ou peut-être famille ce
rythme ça lui se fait d'essayer ça
tourne mal tu as essayé ça peut
peut-être le tour de nous faire enfin
enfin je reprendrai soirée beaucoup plus
intéressante durable à se dire que ma
femme a de la chance que je ne peux pas
regarder mes propres vidéos tu vas
l'audience le voile se lève sur ta pas
les vidéos bas du corps oui oui je
pourrais tu entend en plus comme en plus
on en fait encore pire qu'elle ne voit
quoi faire quelques coups de chaud je
dis rien ne dit rien le pion des deux
était proche de la main et dès demain
ils n'étaient pas empoisonner très
comestible
mais bon on pousse ta vraie vie ici
chers qu'ils demandent c'est quand ton
prochain tournoi alors ton prochain
tournoi 16 îles canaries ouais en fait
ces canaris en mars
je te réponds toujours une pause c'est
donc ces gens c'est un endroit qu'il
faut éviter pour les vacances en fin
mars les îles canaries
je serai alors faut pas que l'on vidéo
ce sera encore pire que les mines
châssis que tu te fais taper par un 14
cents la ville joue pas mal fier et me
remettre au nom des pions sont même des
échelles attention nous tous vous les
voix de l'âme je sais pas
ce que tu vends du rêve les gens disent
nouvelle zélande gibraltar canaries ces
débats m les bahamas ensuite les gens
dit c'est ça la vie de 2005
ouais c'est du sûr ça il faut pas trop
mieux classé que ça peut tu joues à
louvain ou mois à paris on ne sait pas
si une fille que vichy à anzhi bombe
alpes le tout ce à quoi tient un niveau
à ne pas dépasser quoi toi tu arrives
sur surtout pas quoi
surtout ne jamais dépasser elle n'a pas
voulu servir mater
l'avion prend je n'irai jamais eu droit
qu'à 5 je pensais toi j'ai un roi et vii
n'était pas sûr que tu vas t'en non mais
je peux faire échec échec jusqu'à m6 un
bond à manger sain croix sur la cause
des jeunes proches 5000 rush américain
autre pierre aller ok j'ai compris tu as
et replace sa main et fit sa préférence
mais bon est-ce que c'était vraiment
gagnant les gars vous avez dit en live
que je vais pas trop mal ic ir wali
pétrole du coup et je sens quand même
très dépendant à sa femme écrit
plusieurs fois que sa femme a entendu
très content tout ça il y avait en effet
requis chambre dans le jazz ne mange pas
je vais pas dire son message mais bon
c'est le jeu c'est le beau je veux voir
ça c'est le beau jeu en fait je pense
pas la même chose que matt en fait mais
je voulais pas lire et du coup matelas
écrit à quelque part il se réhabilite
après le putsch qui s'est pris d'après
le poutrage en règle que tu t'es pris
là on encore parler des cours collectifs
pour les clubs là qu'on a lancé quoi ça
ça marche ce sont des clubs qui envoient
des demandes et où c'est la folie quoi
alors c'est quoi le principe mais en
fait monté dont ceux moi j'ai pas
compris moi en fait été tu as tu t'es
dans un club d'échecs que bonté l'afld
ont tu te dis c'est très bien regarder
pourquoi l'équipe dans mon club
peut-être a déjà des cours collectifs on
est peut-être que tu as tu as enfin le
mec donne des cours il n'est pas
forcément super fort enfin tu as tu
envie d'avoir des meilleurs courts et là
du coup les cours bitstream ont déjà
c'est complètement bio ça faut le savoir
c'est très important je tiens je tiens à
souligner ce ce côté là parce qu'on pas
de transport tout par internet
la laddh et est-ce qu'on ne brûle pas du
carbone sur internet web et moins on va
déjà déjà on n'use pas de la zone quoi
non plus en plus ces serveurs sont à
l'étranger ou quoi tu pollues tu pollues
pas en france donc quelque part tous les
défauts le un métier c'est comme c'est
comme les voitures électriques et
voitures électriques en fait ça pollue
beaucoup puisque tête à l'extraction des
métaux rares et tout ça en fait c'est
très polluant mais ces polluants chez
les autres et pousser bien c'est comme
un jeu de chars mobile qua non à une
huile émis en france donc la non mais
avons voulu et plus loin faux faux tu
vois tu tues tu veux ça ne peut pas
venir à fukushima par exemple très bien
ça s'éloigne et donc à la limite ce
n'est plus en france mais à verrettes
donc leur ai donc pourquoi l'équipe pour
ton club et donc tous par tous par
internet tout par internet par les gens
peuvent être dans le club ensemble
steven lumbala rétroprojecteur le micro
est aussi le truc qui est bien c'est que
le court est enregistrée donc là
automatiquement tu peux revoir le court
après nous avons même les hawks ans ils
ont pas forcément tort non ils ont même
peut-être raison les absents ont raison
et même duarte a fait le court un an
après ta tête envie de revoir le court
alors que sinon le prof qu'il ya un an
après il trop fait même cour à merde on
l'avait déjà vu celui-là web vous avez
oublié les mecs ah merde alors que la
automatiquement tu regardes tous
d'économique plus bio ouais pas mal pas
mal
ok faire plus d'économies
et à l'enregistrement en fait c'est
difficile de trouver des moins si tu
veux j'ai un peu de mal
j'aimerais bien là tu vois pas ce que
les gens après on dira il fait de la pub
pour ses cours alors que vont à la
limite tu vois et au caire une question
est ce que si jamais je suis pas en club
mais que bon j'ai quelques potes je peux
faire un cours collectif way tu peux
aussi tu peux aussi de faire mais tu
peux aussi le faire en fait comme ça tu
te connectes avec tes potes sur zoomer
et c'est le système qu'on utilise deux
conférences et tu peux tu peux être
jusqu'à 50 grammes
en direct après tu peux aussi avoir en
replay tu peux tu peux être temps que
auquel aucun nom mais ça va pas mal quoi
c'est intéressant les gens disent que tu
rates des coûts non mais sûrement mais
bon ça m'a l'air vraiment intéressant
quand même ce que je ferais tu te sens
bien la balle je fais échec
et puis je refais richesse une
fourchette de trique
mais sur un trident double échappement
c'est pareil les bras
l'ailleurs est une case la belle
victoire belle victoire fab vacances et
donc lucas ganic scène sur neuf mois
sabre doré allez on accepte seulement
doré bon ça au sabre laser qu'on va voir
ça doit être ça ça me fait un peu penser
aux chevaliers du zodiaque lequel je
suis pas un joueur de ce calibre il fera
des sabres doré tu penses le chevalier
d'or en fait ouais pour une sorte de
sage eater et je regardais pas trop un
dessin animé ce que je disais à vérin
fois amusé j'ai revu bon enfin tard n'y
a pas si longtemps les quelques années
mais je vous fait j'avais un pote qui
aimait bien qu'ils avaient les dvd tous
le jeudi richard garneau e bonds pas si
mal quoi c'est pas si mal
non j'ai jamais vraiment non mais génère
un petit peu non non mais j'ai bien le
mec armure rouge
pégase mois c'est long oui mais l'air
sympa mais c'est lui qui a envoyé les
chaînes non non non les chaînes chaud
vers ses plus hauts de six chaînes shawn
je crois sans nom savourait-il et les
photos pour le grand duché ce tour il a
les cheveux verts aussi pas mal je vais
pas le clip qui en fait donc le héros
s'essaya c'est son nom est il à la
remise de pégase que des trucs rouge et
sens on m'a taxé des émetteurs de
pigasse quoi on les plaint de coups de
poing c'est puissance intéressante et
voilà l'autre avec ses chaînes les
pommes avait dit tout ça c'est pharand
fatwa chacun peut son truc et phoenix
aussi qui est ou bien comme le 15 mai il
y aura de ses cendres tu dis les gens
pouvaient mourir mais n'ont fait qu'à ce
moment là
comme c'est un problème alors du coup
baveux membres du scar direct comme ça
c'est mieux tu as tu j'abandonne carré
dit bon ben bella est plus là me suis
dit mais laissons ça ne m'intéresse pas
du tout nous allons commencer à deadpool
quelque part ouais
car d'être poule 2 qui va sortir très
bientôt la femme ouais bon mais n'est-il
pas trop vulgaire pour passer au cinéma
ces revendications se pose la team le
team de droite passe au cinéma quoi hier
seraient vus liga est peut-être que par
j'ai cru que c'était disque édition la
vulgaire quoi sa vulgarité n'a pas
d'égal d'ailleurs des innus qui ne
comprend pas les coûts quoi il regarde
écoute ta partie il se dit non non non
non on sens marin non mais là on est en
mode on est en mode tranquille où quand
on est parvenus les flics est parti on
joue contre les spectateurs on rigole et
tout ça c'est un peu l'objectif du
stream c'est la bonne humeur meurs meurs
demain
[Musique]
et du coup ça te fait du bien ton
opération au nez là tu respires nous y
tue ta je sais pas très bien à une
droite mais j'ai pas emporté la gauche
planum beaucoup moins la gauche mais la
droite minute mais tu sens une
différence ouais alors toxicologiques
normes et si enfin vivement je me feront
seulement la tétée objectif je ne sais
pas tu as et une flore flou qu'il dit on
fait comment pour te défie info faut
défier fab libye tu viendras sur check
point comme live d'ayato qui est très
content de ma partie contre apple
non mais ça c'est marrant parce que
l'ambition que ça fait un espèce de
bosses et partie compte rapsol sur la
chaîne d'apps d'ailleurs en plus il va
être content que ça me fait plaisir
parce que du coup études il invite un
mec qui joue aux échecs
aff est ce que je vais faire des vues
quoi tu as cas les gens qui vont me
regarder finalement il ya vu des gens
méchants qui est déjà miss interview
quoi déjà la veille dans l'espace de
trois heures 1
du coup peut-être ça donnera envie à
d'autres personnes de parler d'échec
mais tu vois en l'espace de près de
trois heures 1400 vu c'est pas mal je
passe il ya beaucoup de commentaires
mais c'est pareil c'est pas bien ça se
passe bien comme vidéo plus que quand
une partie contre magnus ou quoi atteint
canada ouais bah c'est un petit piège
ouais bah mais peut-être toi on va voir
que tu pas devoir absolu c'est qu'à te
faire une petite partie bosse suivant le
plaisir alors d'assaut chess aller vers
d'autres sécheresse comme une vod du
title tuesday est elle prévue qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que je change d'une vidéo
mais le truc s'il n'y a pas eu title
qu'user mardi dernier mais je mettrais
un triplé de taille tels tuesday
précédent bon lundi soit ces deux
amoureux
je me donne un cours sur le mans donc je
vous dis tiens mes journaux invitation
quoi t'as fait quoi ta par les théories
ta part les cinq gardes et non en fait
c'est jouable ce truc là c'est pas si
mauvais en fait pas assez très mauvais
mais
et tu peux entrer que c'est pire que ce
que c'est ce que ce n'est il ya un piège
que j'imagine qu'elle va les prendre et
cac et prend 2,5 damas cinq échecs
oui bon d'accord même genre aventure il
ya eu un title tuesday un an fait
prévenu title fusée c'est que il ya eu
problème de serveur il a été plus ou
moins nuls et mrdja closeraie plutôt
plus que moins d'un tiers
il ya pierre qui demande fabien
franchement tu ne t'en demi pas quand tu
joues contre des losers comme nous tu
peux dire oui on ne sera pas vexer on
comprend bombe a fait au monde et à ce
jeu là je prends pas ça comme des
parties non officiel je cherche pas à
être à fond quoi mais en fait on est là
on discute on rigole si en plus ça vous
fait plaisir à tous c'est cool mais je
suis content je serais content si on
passe une bonne soirée
nous tous qu'en fait il n'y a pas
d'histoire de s'ennuyer ou pas quoi là
on va être en plus on parle pas trop tu
tu fais tes parties s'enchaînent était
tranquille ou quoi l'option la voyez
nous on se marre bien en tout cas votre
bain juste eu marre dont la vulgarité
coiffe un nom va être énorme
le plus de trucs qui se passent à chaque
fois qu'on sera de plus en plus d'îles
ça et joke pas forcément tout le monde
peut comprendre tu manoeuvre et pierre
là je me sens très heureux d'avoir joué
un jeu le sang chaud lapierre 77 44 11
je pense qu'il va subir une soirée vidéo
bitstream android
ça va être terrible jambes ou végétales
je comprends fait chez nous qui dit
bonsoir tout le monde
après le boucher vegan le jambon végétal
matière ça le fait marrer firent ça le
fait marrer easy jet risi à l'égard
était déjà que vous êtes dans la chambre
à coucher tous les sens à nos vidéos
youtube fait attention pierre
envoie-t-on de ressortir les posteurs
maintenant c'est très insidieux très
insidieux on va sortir des posters
poster poster des stream
on rigole on rigole mais sa femme frère
henri kassy fait de ces mises aux
échoppes du coup je crois qu'elle va
vraiment en avoir marre à la pauvre
vraiment désolé en ciel nous écoute on
s'excuse on s'excuse par les excuses une
fois de plus que si tu veux tu écris ce
pari jamais ça sur une belle case des
quatre pour le fou mauvaises odeurs de
manger sain
oui marre d'entendre ça lui est bien
salut youtube et bienvenue dans cette
pour cette nouvelle vidéo
salut femmes stajic m salut à tous cette
intro à les mythiques nos chances qu on
la changera à jamais morte entraîne peu
exposé par habitude après quoi oui je
sais mais avait joueur du grenier qui
répondent à un moment donné ce que vous
avez pensé à changer d'un 3 ont donné
tout et puis disent eh bah il aurait
fallu le faire avant en fait ils boudent
un moment en fait tu peux plus quoi
c'est une habitude et puis les gens
attendent et pour les live commence
surtout parillaud ça c'est pour les live
a dû faire un truc marrant damage 6
damage 7 pour le force à aller en eux
bientôt les retours heures mais je sais
que tu allais faire maintenant ils
croient f1 tourer un multipartisme c'est
ce que je fais mon monteur donc tu as 10
des coûts genoux devant de choses bon ça
sont relativement l'intrus allait donner
plus ou moins mythique notre crypton
mention made me string qui écrit chéri
on fait quoi ce week-end pour
interrogation bas j'ai pris une petite
plaie ni sur les stands yens c'est toi
alors prié les vidéos de gas lift au
salut ne m'a pas beaucoup il y en a 17
sa rapide t'inquiète on se dope les
intros devrait peut-être vendre un
abonnement à gémir l'abonnement netflix
à 7 euros
là il ya une tonne de carbone que j'ai
commencé à regarder je sais pas si tu as
le coin altered carbone la can sortie on
m'a conseillé éventuellement la casa de
papel c'est une série ouais donc je vais
l'espagnol mais non la casa del pape et
les abats espagnol est en fait ce qui se
passe je suis pas genre des deux voleurs
quoi on va dire qu'ils s'enferment dans
une banque où il ya une machine plus du
fric et puis bah ils impriment quoi
voilà ils puissent à part comme ça
après je passe il se passe après je me
suis pas fait spolier plus quoi mais
j'ose art qu'on ne parle mais alors je
sais pas je suis remis à quand une balle
en fête
oui mais faire moi aussi
bon bah je refais que mieux comprendre
n'ont jamais compris pourquoi
mais non je vais te faisait longtemps je
les ai pas vus fin je les ai fait une
fois je suive en direct à l'époque
et puis l'homme sait pas trop quoi
regarder je n'ai pas de séries qui me
branche est trop et je me suis dit bon
il va se refaire ça que non mais walking
dead ça m'a saoulé ben je la regarde et
je suis pas très long buisson acton jeu
en fait je tenais pas y met donc quelque
part non sérieux et sept chauffeurs mais
si je veux le faire
c'est marrant mais n'ont pas
complètement fini mais moi j'aime bien
le fait qu'ils soient nombreux cas ils
sont complètement nul en fait tu peux
les se met facilement mais c'est leur
mort mais je sais que je vais bien
plants vs zombies collègue marie je
pense que le jeu est plus fun
puis surtout qu'il ya d'autres
personnages vers les autres humains ben
en fait de base ils peuvent être très
hostile
donc faut peut-être mieux lecture ici
coiffe dégager ce qu'ils veulent quand
ils veulent être les derniers matches
sur terre battue ne sais pas en fait
mais
je regarde un peu les appeler de joueur
du grenier il y en a ils étaient armés
donc joueur du grenier à bombannes lui
avaient pas vraiment d'armes les autres
avait beaucoup de munitions donc il
s'est dit je vais l'écouter tu venu soir
menaçant leur bouffe je l'offre en tout
cas enfin dégage et du coup il leur a
balancé des zombies dans la galerie des
maladies bats toi
du coup les ont vidés ont défoncé et en
a profité pour les défenses et après
aussi
c'est intelligent qu'un tactique et la
chance qu'il a grillé puis il ya eu
cette tactique dans walking dead en fait
d'utiliser les zombies pour entre autres
mind hunter série policière datant même
mais du coup pierre de ses 75 77 je
comprends pourquoi safa l'on peut plus
quoi il se fait blitz rimer netflix qui
il fait le grand chelem qua non pour
tout le monde quand il finit quantifier
des vidéos des chèques tepa dame b 6 à
utiliser de donc ici je suis dans le
coup se sentent de bain tout commence il
a besoin on encaisse trop de choses
non justin mais si je pense que tous les
shoots yaghi non t'inquiète on fait ça
de j'espère que vous faites pas ça à
trois ou quatre parce qu'après il
commence il commence à m'inquiéter
lapierre 67 44 11
ça commence à me
[Musique]
ça commence à m'inquiéter succulent
sérieusement inquiété en fait
maggie qui écrit après il enchaîne avec
quelques avec quelques épisodes de dbz
et il se termine sur fifa je crois que
pierre il doit dire merde pourquoi
j'écris sur ce tirage de la phase on
joue en double ont maintenant il ya
matam et à madrid stream dans le dans le
dans le chatt pierre ne peut qu une
chance qu'il n'a plus aucune chance à
ses fils un jour nouveau qui viennent
sur le discorde
bob sapp aux femmes elle va entendre les
outils de téléphone du smart boubou bon
vu que c'est marrant ils essayent de
nous calmer mais attention
mais pas de stress et nous promet une
fille rassure les discordes vente
attendra yamadaya mayama te fais gaffe
si un mec qui s'appelle matt à faire il
va te voir te pousse ray mais n'inquiète
pas trop il poutre toute personne en
fait je sais pas j'ai entendu toujours
dire je vais te foutrais chaque fois tu
regardes le résultat des partis c'est
moi mais il est parti du principe que la
menace était plus fort taux d'exécution
et puis bal en quantité menaces co2
poutrage mais oui c'est vrai je te
foutrais en fait mais bon ça sert à ce
qu'une menace quoi il ne désespère pas
quoi on s'est dit bonjour comme la
mecque de la marque où je peux koala
pilote méningite org
bon on va encaisser
même à tafer était pas si bien là tout
d'un coup je pensais qu'il avait
peut-être des trucs va peut-être mais
manger quoi - géorgie chinois j'étais
prévenue
bon ça mais ta famille posture devenir
moniteur tu viens parce qu'on part dans
dix minutes
tu peux venir avec enfin et donkey et
nous réjouit pourquoi barrès et lionel
bah c'est axa doit tout à l'heure en
fait
aïe j'avais l'impression de te la voir
des amis en fait non je pensais que tu
nous monniais quoi ce que je te dis tu
faisais le nouveau rial quoi parle de
toi non ces lyonnais ces lyonnais qui
regardent peut-être le stream d'ailleurs
donc du coup on dira que c'était mieux
c'était bien quand tu es tout seul quoi
ouais mais complètement
[Musique]
ah c'est joli ça allait re manche contre
il ya eu 55 points
ben avec un petit drapeau français quoi
j'imagine que j'aime qui suit qui suit
le stream j'imagine oui j'imagine
la composition pour un après ce que la
composition pour le prochain match
donc oui flavio disponible je l'avais
disponibles automatiquement sa nouvelle
passe passe le relais qua non non on va
voir robert lebel qui vont un maxime
lagarde rares vanina après la seule
question c'est ce que sera robert ou à
ruth qui jouera bateau doit
ben en fait ça robert devoir c'est
justement il ya peut-être sa femme qui
sera là tu as lu aussi vous avez tout
épisode tous ces problèmes que leur
femme en fait c'est ma dose de
rayonnement cynober on et ses parents ne
s'est pas ratée quand même pas mal à
beaucoup de courage
with tous les côtés et à tous les coups
du tennis ou droit à un pouvoir finir
avec style star team suisse mais je vais
faire peut-être tu fous les huit mois je
regarde je sais pas qui a et dessins
sont en pin en recul juste on verra
c'est un peu mieux sauter plus tard
on gagne les abonnés de partout en grâce
à cette vidéo on a fait ce plus 50
abonnés grâce à la grâce à toronto
absolvent merci aux sommes allés se
passe devant l'espace de trois heures ça
fera peut-être une centaine d'abonnés en
tout 150 quelque chose comme ça mais
c'est sympa de sa part quoi ça permet de
faire grandir la communauté des joueurs
moins forts pour que matt affaire puisse
enfin gagné une partie tu as d'autres
carrément on lui pique ses abonnés un
festival ça attention
bâle est en fait une dernière la der des
der nières bonne attente qui veut il ya
eu des faits de jeu par 23e du coup mais
un m'apporte qui doit être ok ils
essayent de pousser ma tafer à la
veillée fit jean roy gosses apprend leur
et il voulait jouer tu as les deux
parties fujiwara gosses c'est parti jégo
[ __ ] [ __ ]
bon là on est mal il est composé de jeu
réagi en champion je maintiens équilibre
hockey ou g2 tout de suite je t'adresse
voilà tu fais un coup passif
oui tu sais que c'est loïc qui médite
s'est fait défoncer comme ça avec les
blancs il m'a dit je défonce et tout le
monde avec la grotte afin d'aboutir vrai
qu'il m'a fait g4 g5 ses premières
défaites quoi la clé plusieurs esprits
que tonnelle dégage je prends pas ton
plongée qu'est ce que tu m'as tu as pas
il est tout de suite beaucoup plus dans
l'esprit la récupère
il ya du coup pour budapest j'en ai déjà
une bonne dizaine quoi glaner plus de
dix ans fait reste plus que trois ce que
j'irais là on est vraiment vraiment plus
que quatre places dont une
trois places et demie on va dire et bah
ça part comme des petits pains codes du
nom c'est un peu la bonne nouvelle ça
c'est un peu la bonne nouvelle
5 le stage à budapest mais bon le savez
une façon que est-ce que je suis content
c'est que c'est beaucoup de gens qui
reviennent pas qu'ils ont fait le
premier ça les filles ils sont dix
c'était pas mal de journée dommage pour
les autres qui piratent l'expérience
j'ai envie de te dire bah au caire a
peut-être qu'on fasse pour plus de
stages quoi sa chance à tout le monde
que 34 stages par an est peut-être stage
bio baba du coup si ça marche il faut
tenter d'en faire un deuxième
octobre novembre décembre au ski cette
fantastique en décembre au ski du stream
fait du ski que ce soit en février on va
faire du ski dont petit peu ça tout
manger de l'arac la tête
16 heures on n'est pas très ambitieux au
ski du fromage sont très intéressants
fin du bal que j'essaie de meilleur le
régime rpt à tête je suis pas sur mais
bon tant pis je fais quand même il faut
que tu fasses un petit régime répète
bombe à jimmy dossier je mange que de la
pizza comme le pari que ça soit ça a
très bien marché
[Rires]
c'est réparé la drogue comme une fois
complètement tehani guema contrebas bout
quoi et pas mal quand même la fuji way
lady pierre bat sa femme va se faire de
manière à le chambrer c'est horrible le
pauvre on met on a une communauté
blizzard en soi une communauté française
aime bien quand on les y est tu vas
après j'ai bien rigolé enfin bon on se
fout de leur gueule en fait je vais le
dire clairement c'est de notre gueule
ouais la loi on s'auto fumeaux biologie
elle est pour ça qu il
blitzkrieg fera pour thaïlande qui est
très jolie d'ailleurs d'apprendre et
c'est 3 prend 17 qui a valu à trois qui
les prive de tout afin qu'ils avaient
lieu 4 tourcoing fc 3,8 et peut pas
empêcher qu'il y ait des deux échecs
tour c'est un match je vais montrer ça
c'est beau et menace qui est des autres
c'est un matin par able enfin un parapet
je pense à f3 la foulée ben du coup il
va faire caler le 3 mai c'est beau comme
variante ouais bah ils sont emmenés par
bombes ajoute bon le jour alors là oui
ça là on va voir ce qui suit vous pas ta
pierre qu'il y en ait une communauté
blizzard qui ceux qui restent qui se
ressemble s'assemble et j'ai envie de
dire l envie de dire aussi de leur
leader des trucs les comme nous quoi je
veux dire vous savez que vous êtes fous
les gares et c'est vraiment ça arrive
j'espère que vous que je ne vous
apprends rien en mai moi honnêtement
c'est vraiment en contact de femmes que
que je suis au début j'étais plus ou
moins normalement j'avais des potes un
peu bizarre genre mur tu as donc tu
sentais déjà tu vois le que ça tournait
mal mais mais c'est vraiment au contact
de fable que ça s'est vraiment
développée et je pense que maintenant il
ya plus de retour en arrière c'est trop
tard contaminée ouais c'est fini c'est
un peu comme un zombie quelque part
j'étais manger le cerveau je vais vous
parler enfin me dit tu es tu rigoles
comme un conte d'herta caméra
à force de rigoler aux blagues de fab et
tout ça t'en rendre compte tu tues tu
perds des neurones c'est un peu la syrie
la delà des échecs en fait mais en pire
en pire parce que quand tu regardes
cyril hanouna tu sais ce que tu regardes
quand même tu étais au courant quand tu
regardes femmes le mec a l'air
intelligent il joue aux échecs et c'est
beaucoup plus insidieux c'est un projet
d'abêtissement des masses en de toute
façon fabien faut le dire si on fait
autant du ou quoi c'est cher c'est pas
mis en avant pour rien la chaîne vitrine
non maison les gens ne le savent pas
mais il ya des raisons pour lesquelles
c'est un truc qui est qu'ils regardent
et qu'enfin vous force à regarder ça
sans s'en rendre compte que ça donc dans
les mails sur ce méditer là dessus et
puis on se retrouve bientôt sur la
chaîne s'agit de stream et puis jeudi
prochain survécu à une opération du nez
il y voit là comme mardi title tuesday
s'il a lieu mercredi grand chelem grise
yahoo ce process ligue super flavio tout
ça je dis stream mené partout quoi real
parier tout saint valentin ou qui alors
ça surtout pour bien 70 pour tout court
terme cette vidéo pour vous quoi le
fauve a dit oh [ __ ] ya le talent
approche on mettra des petites
chandelles sans causer barrières quand
tu vas caméra programme phare ambiance
saint valentin
attention pierre quand même parce que
dans trois semaines dans le stream ce
sera un père divorcé qu'on va voir
pour les mecs je suis seul je suis au
bord du suicide
merci de faire des vidéos parce que vous
reportez je sais pas plus que vous dans
ma vie que je suis dieu a commencé à
nous parler sur les vidéos c'est le fun
ça lui ai dit qu'à paris real il va nous
quitter pour parler elle fait gaffe
même pierre fait quand même très
attention à ce que tu es en ce moment
d'écrire pierre ça pourrait très mal
tourner ça pourra tu peux faire un coup
d'ordi a coûté l'état veut sur tous les
fronts communs sur ce chapelet d'îles et
à bientôt